biden's afghan debacle is creating a
refugee crisis around the world now but
good news it seems like it's finally
inspired him to fix the border but don't
get too excited he's not fixing our
border no according to the u.s embassy
the biden administration is set to build
brand new border facilities in
tajikistan
to help house a border agents processing
the throngs of afghans fleeing that
country meanwhile biden's border crisis
here at home continues of course uh here
to react his former senior advisor to
president trump and america first legal
founder
stephen miller stephen thank you very
much now you're
you're you don't you have a title not
just because it's fun to you know go on
television and have conversations you're
actually working very hard america first
legal is doing extraordinary work
including you have a lawsuit looking for
not just information about the nature of
the withdrawal and the debacle of that
but also
how are we vetting these refugees that
are coming here what can you tell us
about that
yeah so we just launched an oversight
request
to get to the bottom of what is and
really more importantly what isn't
happening with the vetting of
afghan nationals and you're right
america first legal is at the leading
edge of efforts to secure our homeland
in these very perilous times when the
administration is doing the exact
opposite but i want to dig in a little
bit into your opening and what's
happening in tajikistan great and what
is going to be happening next with the
afghan refugee flows the administration
is making preparations right now
to open refugee processing
neighboring countries to afghanistan to
allow for continuing and unending
flights into the united states of
america that will primarily be done
in pakistan which is already home to
millions of afghan refugees who fled the
soviets who fled the civil wars who fled
the first taliban rule who fled the
fighting that has gone the last 20 years
and has now fled again because of the
taliban taking control for the second
time so there's a limitless supply of
refugees and obviously tajikistan will
be a part of that too but what does it
mean for us here in america i think a
very important point timmy and it brings
me no pleasure to say this the truth is
the truth and sometimes it hurts
just because you don't like the taliban
doesn't mean that you embrace fully
everything we have here in america we
have to be very cautious here because
the reality is if you've lived your
whole life in afghanistan you may not
have the same views that we do about
women's equality about pluralism about
an independent judiciary about jury
trials about free expression about
tolerance
about non-violence and so
if you have this open-ended resettlement
program
for years and years and years the state
department would like to continue it
what will that do how will that change
the quality of life that we know and
love in america you know and i think
what we're asking for and what we would
like is simply to know what are we doing
to ensure
that the nature of who it is that's
coming here their background and what
we're doing as a commitment to make sure
that there is some kind of assimilation
and a willingness to assimilate i think
that we're all on the same page there
that that's only fair considering they
don't want to just go back to an
environment that is similar to what
they've just escaped steven of america
first legal thank you very much for
being here we're very busy uh days and
years coming up now hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else